This is transduction.
So basically, how to get into the blood-brain barrier.
Thank you, Alex.
Thank you so much for that warm welcome,
and good morning, everyone.
My name is Xin-Hong Alex Chung,
and I'm from the Grotto Narrow Lab,
and I'm excited to share with you
my talk titled CUNY-AEV Interactions with AVR
and LRP6 Toggle Specters Between Vascular
and Neuron Selective Tropism.
A lot of the recent efforts in the field
have focused on identifying receptors
that are being mediated by AVs
for effective transportation across the BBB.
There are receptors such as L6A for PHPB,
LRP6 for AV9X1, and Car4 for 9P31, amongst others.
And even more recently, a lot of focus
has been garnered towards targeting these receptors
for more effective engineering
so that we have increased predictability
when we're thinking about future therapeutics.
As we're going into this landscape
of thinking about future therapeutics,
I believe that there is something
that we should also consider,
which is how binding affinity to these receptors
might play an important factor
when we're thinking about predicting tropism.
Work that's done in the antibody
and nanobody engineering field
has shown that maybe there could be a Goldilocks zone
for binding affinity to a receptor
for effective transactosis across the BBB.
In work done by Bien Nai et al,
they show that some engineered antibodies
that target transferrin receptors
with too high of a binding affinity
ends up getting stuck in these endothelial cells
and don't actually make it across effectively through the BBB.
Conversely, those binders that are too weak
to bind to transferrin receptor
actually never made it through the BBB
because perhaps they were being outcompeted
by endogenous ligands against the transferrin receptor.
And thus, they found that this medium zone
of moderate binding to the transferrin receptor
was the optimal binding affinity
to help for effective transactosis across the BBB.
And we wondered if the same principle could apply to AAVs
as it's trying to cross the blood-brain barrier as well.
And for this, I'm focusing on predominantly
two receptors, AAVR and LRP6.
And we're also looking at our engineered vector,
AAV9X1, and how we can start engineering
future variants of this vector
in hopes that it can become more neurotropic.
AAV9X1 was a previously engineered vector from our lab
which targets AAVR and LRP6 for effective transduction
of endothelial cells, specifically in the CNS of mouse
when they're delivered systemically.
And we wondered if this targeting of endothelial cells
is because of the fact that AAV9X1 is binding too tightly
to AAVR and LRP6 and ended up getting stuck
in these endothelial cells.
And therefore, by weakening its interaction to AAVR
and LRP6, could we see more effective transduction
of the cytosis across the BBB?
So first, I wanted to go and independently
weaken its interaction with AAVR
in hopes to create a more neurotropic vector.
And this stem from recent work that was published in our lab
would showcase that KAPI-10,
which is a further evolved vector from HPEB,
which modified the VR4 loop
to have further detargeting from PKD2,
the binding domain of AAVR.
This change actually was the reason why
there was increased specificity in targeting neurons
in the CNS of mice when this vector, KAPI-10,
was delivered systemically.
And we wondered if by introducing this KAPI-10 loop
into AAV9X1, we could also have this drastic decrease
in its binding affinity to AAVR.
Unfortunately, by just simply substituting
the same VR4 loop onto AAV9X1,
did not dramatically decrease its binding affinity to AAVR.
And therefore, we need to come up with novel ways
to detarget from AAVR.
And luckily, we were able to recently
solve the cryo-EM structure of its interaction,
AAV9X1's interaction with AAVR.
And we were able to identify key residues
that might be responsible for its binding to AAVR.
And by targeting these locuses for effective rational
engineering, we were able to create this beta mutation.
And by introducing this beta mutation to AAV9X1,
we were able to see a dramatic decrease
in its binding affinity to AAVR.
And when we delivered this vector, AAV9X1 beta,
that we're calling, into mice systemically,
we were able to see that this vector became
a pretty specific vector in targeting neurons.
And I think many of you guys might be thinking that AAV9X1
beta is a pretty bad vector when it's targeting neurons
altogether, because it's not targeting that many cells.
And I thought the same thing when I saw these vectors.
And so I wanted to play around with the second receptor, LRP6.
And to see if, by weakening LRP6's interaction
with AAV9X1, we could have a more increased potency
when it comes to targeting neurons.
However, unlike AAVR and AAV9X1,
we don't have a solved cryoenium structure
to identify the specific loci.
And for that, we actually ended up
using a more traditional method by having a scanning tumor
library across a VR8 loop of AAV9X1
to create mutants that could have various binding affinities
to LRP6.
We subjected this library into a magnetic bead conjugated E1,
E2 subdomains of LRP6, and pulled them down.
And we were able to analyze the enrichment values
of the capsits that bound most tightly to LRP6
and those that did not.
And as expected, we were able to see that AAV9X1 is
near the top of the ranking profile,
because we know that AAV9X1 binds with LRP6.
And conversely, AAV9 tends to be at the bottom
of this ranking profile.
And so you guys can think of this ranking profile
as a proxy for binding affinities towards LRP6.
And when we delivered some of the vectors
that were more similar in ranking to AAV9X1,
such as UX5, into my systemically,
we were able to see that its transaction profile is
predominantly still endothelial.
Conversely, variants such as UX1,
which are similar in ranking to AAV9,
and very little transaction altogether.
And when we looked at vectors with higher ranking than UX5
or AAV9X1, we saw that it is still pretty endothelial
in its targeting.
However, when we started to look at variants
that were in between this AAV9X1's binding affinity
and AAV9, we were able to see vectors
that are starting to transcytose across the BBB
and start targeting some of these aster sites.
And I also thought that this vector,
as many of you guys are thinking right now,
is a pretty messy vector.
It is permeating through the BBB,
but it's not at all specific in terms of the tropism
that we would want to see.
And so we wondered by combining these insights
that we gained from understanding the interaction
with AAVR and LRP6,
we could see a highly potent neurotropic vector.
And just to summarize, starting from AAV9X1,
when we weakened independently just AAVR
by introducing this beta mutation,
we saw a sparsely neuronal vector.
And then when we created this vector
with weakened interaction with LRP6,
but not per se with AAVR,
we were able to get this more permeable vector
that goes across the BBB.
And so we wondered by introducing the same B10 mutation
that we introduced to AAV9X1,
could we see a strongly neuronal vector?
And when we did introduce this beta mutation to UX13,
we were able to see this increased potency
when targeting neurons,
and it is predominantly transusing only neurons
when quantified.
Overall, just to summarize my talk,
I was able to start playing around independently
these two dials, AAVR binding affinity
and LRP6 binding affinity
to get to looking at how these binding affinities
are determining its tropism altogether.
And I hope we can take this into consideration
as we're going into future therapeutics research
and trying to have more predictable outcomes
with our engineering efforts.
Thank you so much,
and I open the floor up for questions.
Thank you.
Questions from the audience?
Hi.
Did you look at vector genomes in peripheral organs,
especially at the early time points?
We analyzed these animals
after three to four weeks post-delivery,
so we didn't really look at really early time points
after delivery.
But an important point that you bring up
is the peripheral organs,
something unique that we saw
with introducing this beta mutation
into these AAV variants,
was that we were starting to see
increased transduction of the peripheral nervous system
as well.
You guys can see pretty much in the spring sum
as one representation of how it would perform
like the other peripheral vectors
that were produced from our lab.
And when we looked at organs such as the distal colon,
we saw increased transduction profile there as well.
Okay.
That's true both on the transduction level
as well as on the vector genome per dipole genome.
We didn't do analysis
about quantifying the number of genomes that were found.
We currently are at the stage of just looking
at the protein level of expression.
Okay, thanks.
Thank you, very interesting talk.
I would like to know what your thoughts
are on the actual role of AVR in like,
why do you see this difference in cell targeting?
Given that AVR should be expressed in every cell,
and there's even some indication
that it might be more a sorting signal
than the actual entry receptor?
I think that's a really important question to consider.
Frankly, I don't quite understand
what's happening here either,
but I know there are a lot of really good talks
that are happening around the role of AVR in transduction.
I think AVR in general is very critical
for transduction altogether.
As many of you guys know, knockouts of AVR
might as completely diminishes
systemic delivered AV transduction.
And I think these vectors are so definitely binding to AVR,
but having this Goldilocks zone of binding
maybe perhaps allows AVR to play more of a trafficking role
rather than more of a sticky web
for targeting off-target regions
of other organs that we don't care about.
Right, so you think you still transduce
what you enter astrocytes,
but they don't express them with your new vectors?
We haven't looked at the genomic level yet,
and I think we're hoping to go with methods
that were developed such as Spectre or AV Zombie
to look into the genomic level as well
to see where these vectors are actually ending up.
But at the current moment, we don't really know.
Okay, thank you.
Could I ask you a quick question?
Oh, yes, of course.
So if you're talking about modulating
and thinking about the Goldilocks effect,
analytically, how would you come to this Goldilocks
composition, so...
I think that's a really...
And also another thing,
are you looking chanced into one species,
I mean, one strain of mice,
or have you looked into Balbsey as well,
because we have a lot of precedents regarding C57 BL6,
you know, having a very different tropism
versus Balbsey, we're being very different.
Definitely, so regarding your first point
about how are we defining the Goldilocks zone,
we're actually hoping to take more
of a molecular approach by determining the KD values
of their binding interactions using species such as BLI.
And by doing so, we can start to have this defined region
of the preferred optimal rate of binding of virtual cytosis.
As for the second question, I think it's really important
because I work in non-traditional organisms as well.
Full disclosure, these animals are C57s that we tested them in.
But interestingly, LRP6, if you guys don't know,
is a highly conserved receptor with over 98%
sequence similarity between mice and humans.
And so, hopefully, the same patterns do hold true
in other strains of mice as well,
but we definitely do have to test them
and be able to see if this is true.
Yeah, and perhaps you're going up to NHBs as well,
the next two. That'll be really exciting if we can.
All right, thank you very much.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
So I'm...